bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi tous les étrangers enlevés à
gaza ont été libérés par milieu de
français une journaliste du magazine
elle et un photographe de l'agencé sipa
ils ont été bien traités sur place la
tension reste très vive entre israéliens
et palestiniens
les premiers signes de radicalisation
dans les manifestations contre le cpe
hier soir trois policiers ont été
sérieusement blessées et six étudiants
au moins seront présentés à la justice
à la veille d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation le nombre d'universités
touchées par le mouvement a encore
légèrement augmenter une spectaculaire
opération de démolition sur la côte
d'azur une de plus après dix ans de
bataille judiciaire un restaurant
mcdonald's construit illégalement sur la
plage de cagnes sur mer a été détruit à
la pelleteuse une victoire pour l'état
et pour les défenseurs de
l'environnement les profits records de
la sncf plus d'un milliard deux cents
millions l'an passé grâce à des
réductions d'effectifs de bons résultats
commerciaux mais surtout la vente
d'actifs
les syndicats réclament une plus grande
part du gâteau une nouvelle arme contre
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui contribuent au réchauffement de la
planète
il s'agit de capturer les fumées émises
dans une centrale électrique au danemark
et de les enfouir sous terre le projet
pilote a été inauguré aujourd'hui
enfin la chute en pleine vitesse du
champion olympique de descente antoine
deneriaz pour son retour à la
compétition en suède
sous le choc il a perdu connaissance
quelques instants plus de peur que de
mal
antoine dénériaz ne souffre que de
blessures légères
l'inquiétude n'aura donc pas duré plus
de 24 heures pour les otages français
dans les territoires palestiniens
caroline laurent journaliste au magazine
elle et le photographe qui
l'accompagnait alfred à jakobsbad ai ont
retrouvé la liberté en début d'après
midi
l'autorité palestinienne s'est même
excusé pour cette brève prise d'otage
sur place en revanche la tension
persiste à jérusalem charles enderlin
talal abou rahmeh les pourparlers
parfois tendues ont duré plus de 20
heures et le front populaire a fini par
relâcher
mission ces otages sains et saufs
caroline laurent et alfred yaghobzadeh
ont été conduits au centre culturel
français de gaza aura ses prêts bien
merci beaucoup ça va bien très bien
passé sous bonne escorte de la police
palestinienne
ils ont gagné le barrage de jerez avant
de se rendre au consulat général de
france à jérusalem
si les négociations n'aboutissaient pas
il ya eu des menaces oui sur nos vies
mais très vite sa société l'arrangé je
pense que c'était le moment là après
c'est ça le moment et ça c'est ils ont
été très corrects c'est vrai par lequel
aurait su que vous alliez être libéré
est ce que c'était déjà dans la nuit il
y avait des bruits dans la nuit mais
c'était très confus encore une fois très
confus
il nous disait igor wigwam d'entente
aurait vraiment vous inquiétez pas vous
allez rentrer l'ismans je devrais pas
dire ça mais oui ça va faire c'est
normal pour moi mais pas dans un avenir
proche
gaza est bouclée jusqu'à nouvel ordre
par l'armée israélienne
quant au président palestinien mahmoud
abbas il a écourté précipitamment sa
visite en europe et il s'est rendu à la
prison de jéricho il a dénoncé une
humiliation après l'opération
israélienne lui même en tout cas sans
très affaibli de l'opération
rappelons que depuis la victoire du
hamas il est pourtant le seul
interlocuteur reconnu par israël en
france l'actualité est toujours dominé
par le conflit du cpe nouvelle veillée
d'armes
demain les manifestations se compteront
les manifestants se compteront dans la
rue et après les incidents d'hier à la
sorbonne la question de la sécurité est
posé on craint aussi la présence de
casseurs florence griffon gilles
jacquier vincent kelner des étudiants
qui tourne le dos aux crs cela change
d'hier cet après midi devant la sorbonne
les grévistes ont voulu calmer le jeu on
n'est pas là pour se taper dessus avec
d'autres étudiants séparé hier soir en
tout cas le rassemblement devant la
sorbonne a dégénéré alors que la
manifestation contre le cpe est terminée
des individus choisissent d'affronter
les crs 1 policiers s'effondrent
sérieusement blessé il sera évacué par
les pompiers
on est là pour manifester calmement et
les voilà trip fate
des fleurs des débordements du groupe
parce qu'il ya le gouvernement n'écoute
pas et et voilà et ils ne sont pas là
guillaume benjamin justement que
il ya au bout d'un certain moment où il
n'y a pas de chance
quelques instants plus tard ce sont des
militants apparemment proche de
l'extrême droite qui viennent en
découdre avec les manifestants et crs ne
s'interposent pas drapeau mois relevé
les anarchistes ont les premiers à
riposter contre les militants des samoa
finalement ce sont les gaz lacrymogènes
qui vont séparer les émeutiers
quartier quadrillé depuis trois jours il
ya quand même une manifestation le
fasciste qui parvint jusque là le blanc
peut se poser plein de questions quoi 22
heures les crs décide d'en finir
bilan neuf policiers blessés neuf
interpellations les émeutiers étaient
une majoritairement des étudiants
la question reste entière eu en tout cas
veulent éviter les débordements
ces lycéens préparer cet après midi la
manifestation de berlin ils seront en
première ligne pour encadrer leurs
camarades et de son côté nicolas sarkozy
qui a reçu les représentants de tous les
syndicats concernés par cette journée de
manifestation de demain a demandé aux
forces de l'ordre je cite de la retenue
du sang froid et le strict respect de la
déontologie
toujours à la sorbonne pour la première
fois quelques 250 étudiants se sont
rassemblés ce matin dans le quartier
pour dénoncer fleur blanche à la main
le blocage des universités il estime que
les assemblées générales ne rassemble
qu'une minoritée d'étudiants et que ceux
qui souhaitent poursuivre les cours
n'osent pas toujours s'exprimer
le dernier comptage effectué par l'
agence france presse fait état de 59
universités touchées par le mouvement
sur 84 ces deux de plus qui hier
certains établissements comme ici l'iut
de tours ont voté la fin du blocage
après une dizaine de jours de grève
d'autres en revanche ont rejoint le
mouvement à perpignan ou à toulouse par
exemple pour l'université des sciences
sociales partout en tout cas les débats
se poursuivent à aix reportage nicolas
nuisait christophe là aucun le discours
anti cpe a du mal à passer chez ces
étudiants en droit
pour eux c'est la toute première
assemblée générale qui est un débat
entre les personnes qui se trouvent ici
pour savoir ce que pense la majorité
parce que la fac de droit deux ex qui
est soi-disant à droite
la réputation de cette fac qui s'est
toujours tenu à l'écart des mouvements
sociaux même en mai 68 alors cet âge et
pour certains ça veut dire beaucoup
4 un réveil qui serait quand même tardif
mais espéré et
voilà peut-être un début de mobilisation
de prise de conscience générale les
autres sont là où tout ça ils ont pas
lieu d'être le but c'est qu'on puisse
débattre sereinement et quel moment du
contrat première embauche
mais le débat n'aura pas vraiment lieu
pas de vote ceux qui soutiennent le cpe
titre l'assemblée que des jeunes des
personnes qui a offert des longues
études et les cpe s'adresse aux moins de
25 ans est à 25 ans sera sûrement pas
sorti donc j'ai ça ne concerne pas les
anglais contre le gouvernement la
mobilisation tous les jeunes qui se
mobilisent partout en france alors on
n'a pas la demande et sur le même prix
mais des bulletins on demande aux
présidents des facultés d'organiser des
votes pour ou contre le blocage qu'on ne
le sont pas pas de grève les cours ont
donc lieu normalement à la fac de droit
mais à quelques centaines de mètres de
là contraste saisissant la fac de
lettres occupé depuis quinze jours donc
des actions se prépare encore demain et
samedi en espère une réaction parce que
là je pense qu'on est dans une semaine
vraiment décisive mais bon en même temps
on est déterminés et toute façon la fac
elle restera bloquée tant que c'est que
ce sera bientôt
et ici la mobilisation ne faiblit pas
ils sont prêts à convaincre et prépare
déjà la manifestation de demain
alors depuis plusieurs jours on entend
beaucoup les étudiants mais d'après le
gouvernement le cpe est destiné plus
particulièrement aux jeunes sans
qualification ils sont soixante mille a
quitté l'école chaque année sans diplôme
que pense-t-il du contrat première
embauche à meyzieu près de lyon
reportage benoît gadret philippe est
vrai qu ils sont trop jeunes d'ouvriers
originaires des banlieues lyonnaises
trois parcours similaire pas de
qualification et de multiples contrats
en intérim
le dernier sur ce chantier du tramway
nordine à 19 ans et déjà une seule idée
en tête
embauche comme tout le monde un jazz
sont stables le code à marie ndzié qu'on
n'embauche entendez par là un contrat à
durée indéterminée pour ces jeunes de
moins de 26 ans le contrat première
embauche représentent ils une
opportunité oui ça peut être une chance
comme
comme ça peut être une chose comme ça
peut pas être une chaste si vous
travaillez bien et le patron il est cool
et comprend et tout ça bat bien sûr que
c'est une chance qui vous en bouche
définitivement en fait j'ai des
inconvénients et à des désavantages
c'est ça l'inconvénient majeur
c'est aux yeux de tous la longueur de la
période d'essai la loyauté sert de 24
mois selon maintenant une période
d'essai ce s'appelle en ce moment de
quelques mois un an
au bout d'un an le patron d'un moment
fait son choix qu eux ou dans le moment
il dit non j'ai pas besoin de temps il
faut que je rate pas encore deux ans ça
me fera quatre ans perdus moi je
pourrais pas impossible c'est pour ça
que on ad intérim qui c'est vrai que
c'est des petits contrats qu'on a mais
on a de plus de chances déjà d'être en
gros c'est comme ça que attentes deux
ans et encore deux ans et encore deux
ans chaque fois dans l'immédiat djamel
nordine ait ahmed espère un
renouvellement de leur contrat
car même de courte durée ces missions
permettent d'acquérir de l'expérience en
tout cas le climat politique reste
électrique nouvel incident à l'assemblée
un député ump a mis en cause ségolène
royal les députés socialistes mais aussi
communistes se sont aussitôt levé pour
tenter de convaincre le président de
l'assemblée jean-louis debré de lever la
séance pour demander aussi la démission
du porte-parole du gouvernement jean
françois copé qui les avait rappelé à
l'ordre
quant à dominique de villepin il réunit
ce soir tous ses ministres pour un
séminaire gouvernemental est juste avant
il a renouvelé son appel à un dialogue
avec les syndicats
on écoute nous sommes tous ouverts au
dialogue
nous sommes tous mobilisés pour répondre
aux inquiétudes des jeunes et mieux les
accompagner vers l'emploi
alors la critique principale adressé au
cpe concerne vous le savez la précarité
comment par exemple obtenir un prêt ou
présenter des garanties pour louer un
logement
le gouvernement indique que des
consignes seront données aux banques aux
agences immobilières
impossible bien sûr de vérifier pour le
cpe qui n'est pas encore en application
mais nous avons voulu tester très
concrètement ces garanties pour le sait
et ne contrat nouvelle embauche adoptée
il ya quelques mois et qui présente les
mêmes caractéristiques
voici cette enquête elle est signée pays
le roi édouard perrin nous avons décidé
de tester les banques avec une caméra
cachée
partout où je me suis présenté comme une
salarié en contrat nouvelle embauche à
la recherche d'un prêt immobilier
premier rendez vous au début pas de
problème ici au prête même aux précaires
c'est pas de cdi qui fait tout s'est
passée ta vraiment la surprotection
parce que vous êtes en cdi je vous dis
nous intermittents moi j'en ai été dans
le monde aussi d'intermittents du
spectacle pour cette banque donc le sait
ne n'est pas un handicap mais pour ses
partenaires oui explications quand une
banque vous prêtent de l'argent elles
demandent des garanties
vous devez donc souscrire à un organisme
de cautionnement
il remboursera à votre place en cas
d'insolvabilité problème ils refusent
d'assurer les contrats précaires
est ce le cas pour le sénat on a un
organisme de cautionnement
mais c'est quoi
ils sont assez pointu c'est ok voici les
dossiers soient fois soit vraiment bien
monté quoi c'est à dire que es que ça
passerait avec ce genre de contrat mais
c est nu c'est pour être un problème
voilà au final on me conseille
d'attendre pour emprunter le temps
peut-être pour les banques de mieux
connaître le sait et nous on n'a pas
assez de recul pour savoir comment ça
fonctionne vraiment peut-être est-ce que
dans cinq six ans on pourra dire en fin
de compte le sénat c'est ça c'est réglo
et puis les gens sont vraiment embauchés
en cdi
alors peut-être fessard est carrément se
rend compte que c'est une grosse
escroquerie et que les gens profitent
autres établissements même discours
cette banque aussi de bien me prêter de
l'argent mais son organisme de
cautionnement refusera mon dossier je
suis persuadé que créer irano que
l'organisme de cautionnement dire à
nérac
à cause d'eux à cause de l'âge du contre
un nouvel an le juge allan est ce que ça
veut dire qu'à ce moment là où mon
dossier si j'ai un cdi avec les mêmes
conditions est-ce que ça que je fais oui
mais au niveau du crédit
il vaut mieux un cdi cas céder à cassel
troisième et dernier essai ici le
conseiller m'explique qu'il y a toujours
une solution même si l'organisme de
cautionnement refuse monde aussi car la
banque peut prendre une autre garantie
elle pose une hypothèque sur le bien
immobilier
mais en cas d'impayés elle peut vendre
l'appartement ou la maison quand elle le
veut c'est très risqué pour l'emprunteur
si j'ai pas de l'organisme de caution
j'endosse un peu tous les risques en
fait quand même
c'est alors à l'erreur ouais c'est sûr
c'est sûr la fédération bancaire
française a récemment déclaré qu'elle
offrirait au ces et ne les mêmes
garanties qu'aux cdi
après ce test la réalité paraît plus
nuancé voilà et puis notez le devin
france 2 consacre une soirée
d'information à ce conflit avec à 20h50
à vous de juger un grand débat en direct
arlette chabot recevra de nombreux
étudiants ainsi que le ministre de
l'éducation gilles de robien ou encore
martine aubry et françois chérèque
autres titres de l'actualité cette
nouvelle opération de démolition de
grande ampleur sur la côte d'azur après
dix ans de procédure les pelleteuses
sont entrées en action un restaurant
mcdonald's construit illégalement sur la
plage à cagnes sur mer a été détruit
olivier théron frédéric cerulli sur
place encore quelques bouchées et du
mcdo de la plage il ne restera plus rien
malgré les deux permis de construire
délivré par la mairie de cagnes sur mer
le tribunal administratif saisi par la
préfecture des alpes-maritimes a tranché
le mcdo construit sur le domaine public
maritime doit disparaître au moment de
la fermeture nous en étions à six
millions et demi de clients qui étaient
passés par le restaurant ce qui fait
pratiquement 1800 clients par jour
donc c'est vrai que demander à chef
d'entreprise son sentiment lorsque son
outil de travail et détruisent et est
évident que c'est beaucoup d'amertume de
tristesse la lumière s'est éteinte la
semaine dernière définitivement en dix
ans le mcdo paillote avait su trouvé ses
adeptes les coins de plage à petits prix
sur la côte d'azur
ça fait recette on nous habitants de
cagnes-sur-mer on revenait le plus
souvent si tu as eu l'allemagne de l'est
la trentaine d'employés a reçu des
offres de reclassement dans d'autres
établissements
le mague de la plage lui sera
définitivement détruit pour la fin du
mois tout comme l'ont été les autres
contrevenants à la loi littoral les
préfectures semble de plus en plus
décidé à jouer du tractopelle pour
libérer la côte de ses scories de béton
en bref un attentat rarissime à la
courneuve près de paris une voiture a
explosé sur l'autoroute elle avait été
piégé les enquêteurs évoquent un
possible règlement
compte le conducteur un homme de 68 ans
connu de la police pour des affaires
financières assez ancienne est mort
son passager a été blessé par miracle il
n'y a pas eu d'autres victimes c'était
en fin de matinée l'autoroute a été
bloquée pendant plusieurs heures la
suite des auditions de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire de l' affaire de
pédophilie d'outreau
les représentants des médias continuent
à être entendu et hier soir notre
consoeur florence aubenas de libération
a par exemple évoqué un dossier en sable
suite des auditions demain d'autres
journalistes se seront entendus à propos
de pédophilie on attend demain de
nouvelles indications du gouvernement
sur la préparation de la conférence de
la famille cette conférence vous ne
savez comporte un volet relatif à la
protection de l'enfance
voici à ce sujet l'expérience menée au
canada depuis trois ans les pédophiles
condamnés peuvent être castré il ne
s'agit pas de castration chimique mais
de castration tout court seuls les
volontaires sont concernés envoyés
spéciaux jérôme soûlard philippe lüthi
il y at il encore une chance d'amour et
de pardon pour cet homme-là au canada
beaucoup s'interrogent sur cette
incroyable histoire
jacques corneau 42 ans le pédophile le
plus connu du pays 200 agression
sexuelle 23 victimes établi un prédateur
multirécidiviste
je regrette ce que j'ai fait quand
j'allais leur a dit je le regrette pas
ce que j'ai fait à chacun de mes
victimes je réclame après une première
condamnation 95 corneau ressort de
prison incapable de contrôler ses
pulsions il récidive à nouveau enfermé
il décide alors d'être le premier
québécois volontaires pour une
castration physique une ablation des
testicules
j'ai utilisé cette méthode blanc oh mais
tu fais moi c'était l'appétit sexuel
qu'elle voulait pas de ce fait la
pulsion sexuelle
j'ai utilisé une méthode qui est
efficace la castration sétif castres je
les utilise et ça fonctionne bien et
j'ai repris le contrôle de ma vie
au québec la castration physique n'est
possible qu'avec des volontaires une
demande doit être formulée devant le
juge avant toute décision on évalue
alors la motivation et la santé mentale
du criminel pendant plusieurs mois
pierre mailloux experts pédopsychiatre
depuis 25 ans a défendu la quasi
totalité de ces dossiers
alors la castration chirurgicale c'est
très simple c'est exactement la même
chose que chez les animaux
que ce soit chez les chevaux les bovins
ou les parts ont fait une petite
incision sur le scrutin et on enlève les
deux testicules
on attache au kop on baisse à la
poubelle alors ça prend 10 minutes
et ici au québec ça coûte 140 dollars
anastasie incluse dans le monde médical
la méthode jugées barbares ne fait pas
l'unanimité les commissions d'éthique
médicale ne se sont pas encore
officiellement prononcé les juges doutes
et les experts supposent il est faux de
croire qu'une fois que les testicules
son parti qu'il n'y a plus de vie
sexuelle et plus des vidéos et puis
désir sexuel
ça varie entre 20 40 parfois 50% et ses
hommes notamment rapporté même des
années après la castration une vie
sexuelle active sont capables d'avoir
des relations sexuelles complètes avec
éjaculation et orgasme
on me traitait de barba c'est la seule
c'est le meilleur moyen médical que je
cotise pour aider aux délinquants
sexuels c'est la castration chirurgicale
c'est le meilleur la castration chimique
fait le même effet chez plusieurs
patients à quelques poils près excepté
qu'elle est temporaire
rappelons nous que la délinquance
sexuelle est un problème permanent à ce
jour huit pédophiles ont été volontaires
pour cette opération les autres
criminels sont traités dans cet hôpital
par castration chimique
une prise de médicaments à vie pour
éliminer tout désir sexuel également
payés par l'état
l'accompagnement thérapeutique
obligatoire pour tous les pédophiles
six heures par semaine 18 mois de
traitement c'est bien et mal et
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce que je fais je
suis les conseils cage une thérapie
financiers les traitements peuvent durer
toute la vie
c'est le médecin qui décide et gare à
ceux qui ne répondrait pas au rendez
vous
obligatoire de l'équipe médicale ci est
maintenant à ce moment-là
automatiquement ça devient bris
formation l'agent de probation ramène le
code va juger eu un bris probation ici
c'est passé de 18 mois de prison
castration physique ou chimique suivi
thérapeutique obligatoire depuis 25 ans
le québec a choisi une politique de
suivi très strict des délinquants
sexuels avec une réussite
les taux de récidive des pédophiles sont
aujourd'hui inférieurs à 5% à l'étranger
en bref le procès de zacarias moussaoui
a finalement repris aux états unis après
deux jours de suspension suite à une
erreur de procédure cette témoin cité
par l'accusation ne pourront pas être
entendus c'est une première victoire
entre guillemets pour les défenseurs du
français
et puis c'est finalement en serbie dans
sa ville natale de podz areva tx que
slobodan milosevic sera enterré samedi
prochain sa dépouille est arrivée à
belgrade sous les vivats de plusieurs
centaines de personnes massées à
l'aéroport malgré la neige il n'y aura
pas d'obsèques d'état mais le corps sera
exposé pendant deux jours dans la
capitale de la république yougoslave
économie lyon par les tiers des
bénéfices qui flambent pour les grandes
entreprises françaises plus inattendu la
sncf a communiqué aujourd'hui est
officiellement ces résultats les profits
dépassent largement le milliard d'euros
c'est du jamais vu stéphane despinoy
vincent kelner ce sont sans aucun doute
les meilleurs résultats de l'histoire de
la sncf un bénéfice multiplié par 3 1,3
milliard d'euros contre 444 millions
l'an dernier
un résultat qui s'explique en partie par
des plus values la sncf a vendu ses
participations dans la société
hydroélectrique du midi et dans cegetel
gains 800 millions d'euros
deuxième explication moins de charges
sociales avec une diminution des
effectifs 3590 départs à la retraite non
remplacés mais globalement la sncf
transporte surtout plus de voyageurs + 3
% pour les tgv 3 % pour les transilien
et 6 ennemis pour les ter
ces résultats ne tombent pas du ciel
c'est une trajectoire amorcée depuis
2001 après le choc des 35 heures d'avoir
amorcé cette courbe de d'amélioration
des résultats en 2003 et un petit accroc
avec la grève des retraites qui nous a
coûté 250 millions d'euros
mais la courbe et la tendance était très
nette et 2005
et dans cette tendance seul point noir
si le fret a réduit de moitié son
déficit il reste dans le rouge le plan
de sauvetage des marchandises engloutir
à lui seul 700 millions d'euros de
bénéfices en tout cas les résultats
historiquement bon donne des idées aux
syndicats ils réclament des discussions
sur les salaires pour que les cheminots
touchent leur part du gâteau
les premières condamnations de
viticulteurs suite aux actes de
vandalisme de la semaine dernière quatre
personnes ont été condamnées en
comparution immédiate à un mois de
prison avec sursis un jugement plutôt
clément accueilli en tout cas avec
satisfaction par les deux à 300
viticulteurs rassemblés devant le palais
de justice de montpellier pour soutenir
leur collègue la sécheresse on l'évoqué
tiers en france la menace s'éloigne mais
c'est la grande bretagne qui est touché
de plein fouet 8 millions de
britanniques pour devoir limiter leur
consommation d'eau arrosage interdite
ben est conseillé c'est du jamais vu
depuis 33 ans
maryse burgot à londres c'était cet
après midi à londres un soleil radieux
bien loin du cliché selon lequel ici un
parapluie est absolument nécessaire
d'ailleurs dans hyde park tous les
anglais croisés au hasard d'une
promenade disque au pays de sa majesté
il fait toujours beau les gens disent
toujours plus beaucoup à londres en fait
c'est une légende il ne peut pas
tellement il pleut même tellement peu
que c'est la sécheresse dans tout le sud
du pays à partir du mois prochain
ce couple ne sera donc plus autorisé à
arroser le jardin
plus question non plus de laver la
voiture des restrictions que ces anglais
approuvent
même s'il constate que faute d'eau des
arbres sont déjà morts dans leur jardin
plus des années passent et plus le sous
sol est sec et donc la végétation a du
mal à survivre
plusieurs comtés sont touchés le kent et
le sussex n'avait jamais eu aussi peu de
pluie depuis 1921 un survol des
réservoirs d'eau montre combien les
niveaux ont baissé le gouvernement tente
donc de convaincre les consommateurs
d'économiser l'eau fait présentatrice
part de la télévision anglaise explique
par exemple qu'en fermant le robinet en
se brossant les dents on n'utilise plus
qu'un litre d'eau et c'est un peu le
monde à l'envers avec tout le sud de la
grande bretagne aujourd'hui sous un
radieux soleil qui attend désespérément
la pluie cette région du kent surnommé
le jardin de l'angleterre en a perdu
toutes ses couleurs
toujours à propos d'environnement
l'inauguration d'un projet pilote en
europe pour limiter les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre qui contribuent vous le
savez au réchauffement de la planète
il s'agit de capturer les fumées émises
par une centrale électrique en
l'occurrence au danemark
des fumées qui seront ensuite enfoui
sous terre par le biais notamment de
plateforme gazière en norvège
explication agnès monte natalie gray
en pleine mer du nord l'une des plus
grosses plates-formes de norvège sa
teneur on y exploite 20 millions de
mètres cubes de méthane par jour cette
plateforme intéresse des scientifiques
du monde entier comme ceux français
venus la visiter
car on y mène une expérience unique au
monde le gaz est pompée de kilomètres
sous la terre problème il n'est pas pure
il contient un dixième de co2 un gaz à
effet de serre qu'on va séparer du
méthane grâce à un solvant est plutôt
que de le rejeter dans l'atmosphère
il retourne par ses tuyaux sous la mer
il est injecté dans une nappe d'eau
salée à un kilomètre de profondeur en
norvège nous avons une taxe co2 si mu et
mettez du co2 devait payer une taxe
donc nous avons préféré utiliser cet
argent pour stocker le gaz
en dessous la mer ce qui permet de
préserver le climat
voilà comment ils évitent de rejeter un
million de tonnes de co2 par an
encore faudrait-il être sûr qu'il n'y a
pas de danger salle de contrôle de la
plateforme
c'est à partir des données recueillies
ici que des scientifiques comme yann le
gall ots simule le trajet du gaz non
explosif mais toxiques à forte
concentration il faut suivre son
déplacement vérifier qu'il n'y ait pas
de fuite le co2 il reste en place tout
ce qu'on a pu modéliser montre que ça va
rester en place pour les siècles qui
viennent n'en crée pas pas vraiment de
soucis à son voile assure sur cette
opération
puisque ça marche l'idée serait de
généraliser ce principe aux usines
récupérer le co2 et l'enfouir dans
différents types de réservoirs naturels
l'idée fait bondir les écologistes
norvégien bien au courant de la question
une fuite en avant selon eux une façon
de ne pas changer ses habitudes et de
laisser les générations futures gérer
nos projets pendant des milliers
d'années it is more
c'est immoral de notre part de léser ses
déchets aux générations futures un
millier d'années c'est déjà énorme
et pour vraiment lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique il faudrait en
fait les stocker sous terre
plusieurs milliers d'années à oslo comme
ailleurs le plus difficile sera
probablement de convaincre les opinions
publiques
mais les défenseurs de cette idée ou un
argument rien qu'au large sous le site
de sa teneur on pourrait enterrer toutes
les émissions de rentes pendant six ans
en une catastrophe écologique en alaska
la rupture d'un oléoduc au nord du
cercle polaire
au début du mois entraîne la pire
pollution de l'histoire de cette région
jusqu'à un million de litres de brut ont
fui dans la nature et les opérations de
nettoyage sont rendues très difficiles
par la météo avec des températures
ressenties inférieures à moins 50 degrés
celsius
à propos de pollution le nouveau cheval
de bataille de l'ademe l'agencé de la
maîtrise de l'énergie en france
il faut lutter contre eux le transport
de marchandises en ville qui
représenterait 50 % la moitié du gazole
consommé l'ademe préconise pour cela un
remède
les livraisons qui serait beaucoup plus
écologique frédéric mental pour une
vigne et la vie d'un yaourt à la fraise
se résume à un mot voyager car avant de
débarquer dans les rayons de vos
supermarchés les yaourt à la fraise ont
presque parcouru l'équivalent d'un paris
tokyo
mais ça les consommateurs l'ignorent si
la france qui viennent il parcourt pas
du centre à 100 km si c'est pas la
france et la sérénité
émile kg mais c'est jusqu'à 9000
kilomètres comme sa réponse par tous
réunir les ingrédients fraises les peaux
tient du marathon 3500 km au compteur
pour assembler un simple pot d'après une
étude allemande le yaourt arrive jusqu'à
nos frigos au bout de neuf mille 115km
fonction de ces différents moyens de
locomotion elle ya le poids yaourt aura
consommé plus ou moins de pétrole
en moyenne on est sur 40 g de pétrole
pour un kilo de yaourt on sait pas
impôts c'est un kélonia c'est beaucoup
de yaourt et si vous transportez vos
pots de yaourt dans le coffre de votre
voiture
inévitablement vous aller polluer mais
de là à changer ses habitudes des
supermarchés à 400 km on est bien obligé
de la prendre pour transporter beaucoup
de choses j'aurais du mal sans la
voiture quand on a deux enfants qu'on
doit faire les conseils de ses enfants
les transports en commun cette
appartenance à un idéal fin je vous
trouve des excuses
alors pour ne plus chercher d'excusés
vous pouvez vous faire livrer les
courses à domicile
globalement plus économique et plus
écologique que la voiture
pour les autres il y a encore le caddie
à roulettes
garanti sans gaz à effet de serre
sentait la journée nationale du sommeil
on en parlait dès hier près de la moitié
des français estiment ne pas dormir
assez alors pour pallier ce manque de
repos une tendance la sieste même au
travail les entreprises s'y mettent
petit à petit julia delage guillaume
flottera on en a tous rêvé ses employées
l'ont fait tous les jours 10 ou 20
minutes deux siestes juste après le
déjeuner le problème c'est qu'on
s'habitue vite au bras de morphée
mais qu'il faut bien retourner
travailler allez savoir
oui le temps je me sens une minute ça va
peut être partie dans cette entreprise
artisanale près de rouen certains
l'avouent ils ne pourraient plus s'en
passer
je ne m'autorisais pas à faire de sieste
et quand on nous l'a proposé je me suis
rendu compte que je me sentais vraiment
beaucoup mieux moi je repars
l'après-midi en forme et le soir aussi
j'ai des enfants donc je suis un prêt
les écouter parce que je suis moins
fatigué quoi aujourd'hui un français sur
quatre pratiques la sieste au moins une
fois par semaine mais souvent le week
end
or des études sur le sommeil l'ont
prouvé quinze minutes de repos dans la
journée c'est 1h30 de gagner sur la nuit
et donc du temps de travail en plus
alors la sieste réservé aux flemmards
peut-être une idée reçue
c'est peut être fainéant quand on en
profite pour dormir deux heures
mais quand on fait une pause que
raisonnable qui devraient être aménagés
dans toutes les grandes entreprises
à ce moment là c'est bénéfique pour tout
le monde on comprit pour l'entreprise
dans une réaction améliorer mémoire à
court terme accru les bienfaits de la
sieste seraient multiples certains sont
persuadés dans cette entreprise
autrichienne les ouvriers travaillent 20
minutes et se repose
20 minutes
plus fort encore les chinois ont intégré
le droit à la sieste dans leur
constitution fait être à méditer la
lutte contre la violence dans les stades
avec cette annonce de nicolas sarkozy
tout al heure trente supporters du paris
saint germain vont être interdits de
stades dès dimanche c'est ce qu'il a
indiqué à l'assemblée 30 personnes qui
seront convoqués au commissariat
le temps de la rencontre le club
parisien va rencontrer auxerre jusqu'à
présent il fallait une décision
judiciaire pour fermer l'accès à des
supporters les sports encore avec une
grosse frayeur pour antoine dénériaz le
champion olympique faisait son retour à
la compétition il a été victime d'une
chute spectaculaire mais heureusement
sans gravité finalement julien benedetto
voilà ce qui s'appelle redescendre de
son petit nuage
champion olympique il ya trois semaines
antoine deneriaz termine sa saison dans
les faits les protections à re en suède
la violence du choc lui fait perdre son
casque le skieur de mort et lyon perd
connaissance quelques instants une
grosse frayeur à priori sans conséquence
le champion olympique souffre d'un
traumatisme crânien mais ce soir il est
sorti de l'hôpital autre roulé boulé de
la journée klaus scroll bilan pour
l'autrichien poignet et tibias brisé
dire que les chutes font partie de ce
sport est un doux euphémisme
lancé à près de 150 km heure les
descendeurs sont des funambules dans le
grand cirque blanc et les meilleurs ont
tous au moins une fois mordu la neige
ici herman mayer aux jeux de nagano en
1998 l'autrichien deviendra champion
olympique quelques jours plus tard
malheureusement les protections en bord
de piste ne font pas toujours suffisante
en 2001 le suisse beltrame étiez devenu
paraplégique après sa chute à val
d'isère
ce jour là c'est ce qui avait transpercé
les filets de sécurité les risques du
métier n'ont jamais découragé antoine
deneriaz déjà gravement blessé au genou
en janvier 2005 il est devenu champion
olympique seulement un an plus tard et
puis toujours en suède d'un coup de
chapeau à carole montillet dont c'était
aujourd'hui la dernière descente
à 32 ans la championne veut prendre sa
retraite et elle a l'intention de se
lancer notamment dans le rallye
automobile
une nouvelle version des noces de figaro
une version qui divise le célèbre opéra
de mozart a été adaptée aux temps
modernes
sacrilège ou éclair de génie le public
de l'opéra de paris est très partagée
sophie jouve philippe jasmin il y avait
comme un mélange d'appréhension et
d'excitation ce soir là le père a aussi
bien du côté du public que du côté des
chanteurs
ces noces de figaro de mozart à l'été
lettre comme l'indiquent leurs sous
titres une folle folle journée et dès
l'ouverture le metteur en scène
christoph marthaler donne le ton une
arrière boutique en allemagne de l'est
des personnages à la deschiens figaro
par exemple est un garçon de café jean
torride
on est à la façon des mozart vraiment
libres parce que je joue vraiment
librement dans les rythmes judith
louable que l'ironie il n'y pas un
ennemi très archaïque manière libre et
moderne
le conflit de classes moteur de l'oeuvre
est respecté mais toutes les situations
sont détournés avec des gags et des
surprises à l'appel jusqu'aux classes
traditionnelles de mozart remplacé par
un étrange musiciens verdict au bout de
ces trois heures
c'est du cirque music hall c'est
insupportable
on assassine de mozart moi j'aime
beaucoup et je suis scandalisée par ces
gens qui ne comprennent rien qui crient
donc en même temps que publics
réagissent comme ça c'est très bien
d'ailleurs même au 18e siècle
il réagissait tous les gens qui se
battaient importante le spectacle en
live à porto de chose que ce qu'on
entend sur des disques voix magnifique
comme celle de chérubins et mise en
scène provocatrice ses noces qui font
déjà polémique illustre bien les
nouvelles audaces de l'opéra pas
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite la météo patrice
drevet dans un instant vous retrouvez la
série fête de famille à demain